hi i'm paul betterly and i play vision
or the vision in one division
and i am elizabeth olsen and i
play wanda maximum and we are both here
with buzzfeed to answer all of your
burning questions
when did you first find out that wanda
and vision would be getting their own
series
i had just died in infinity war
my contract was up and i got a call from
the boss
saying come into the office and i well
we all know what that means so i looked
at my wife and i went
i think i'm getting a can i was very
nervous as i got over there
and i wanted everybody to feel
comfortable and not feel icky about the
whole thing because i thought they were
going to be gentlemen and just look me
in the face and say
it's over and so i went and i said look
just absolutely no half feelings
it's been a great run thank you so much
and they went
wait are you quitting and i went no
aren't you firing me and they went
no we were going to pitch you a tv show
and i went oh excellent
that was how i found out i think
infinity war just come out and we were
about to go
and do pickups for endgame yeah i had a
similar experience but
without the firing part because i still
had work to do on end game
i was just very thrown by the whole tv
part of it all and then when i heard
about the concept
i thought it was perfect for television
and a very original
idea that made me excited and i thought
it'd be fun for
you and i to go at it again one division
uses various sitcom formats and areas
to tell the story do you have a
particular favorite
that we did together the favorite's hard
for me because i feel like that means i
have to like pick my favorite child
which i cannot do
however speaking of children i think the
70s was very fun because i thought it
was very
fun i feel the same there are things
about each and every
era that i i loved i did love the
feeling of
when we came back and shot exteriors
for episode two because
yes it was after the hiatus because of
the pandemic
and everybody was very worried whether
it was even gonna work
and seeming to work and we it was just a
lovely feeling
knowing that this job was going to be
able to finish
so that was a great moment for me so the
first two
juan division episodes are in black and
white and employ a lot of old school
sitcom tricks
what's your favorite behind-the-scenes
memory from filming these
episodes running around backstage with
you and catherine khan
so nervous at the on the first
episode where it was all you know we had
a live studio audience and i was
really resistant to the idea really dug
my heels in and
finally it just yielded and we we we
were there we were doing it and just
running around like idiots bumping into
catherine hahn at the prop table
and then i i i felt like we were all in
school
doing a school play or summer stock or
something i it just felt really great
i immediately think of all the practical
gags our special effects team who are
used to um
you know blowing things up and setting
fire to things and
creating fog and wind and watching them
become puppeteers
of just like the kitchen items that were
floating in the air
and my favorite one was watching two of
our special effects guys
puppeting um a dish rag trying to dry
a cup and it was so complicated and
so frustrating for them they figured it
out but it was
really funny watching them you know
trying to figure out how to bounce a
dish rag to
dry a cup what was it like for you when
we had to
perform in front of a live studio
audience i thought it was terrifying
i was like completely freaked out i had
so much adrenaline and
like first day nerves going and the only
thing that was getting me through was
knowing that i trusted matt shakman and
if it was a failure he would let me
reshoot it the next day
but we didn't he got most of everything
we needed
yes and there's that feeling slightly
when you're starting something you can
kind of delay making choices
for a little while until you find your
feet and this was certainly like
well i guess that's what the show is
and that was it that was um that was
actually a really great
and freeing feeling so one division has
a lot of moments of comedy
so was there ever a moment where you
could stop laughing while trying to film
the scene
yes there have been a few but weirdly
it's usually moments where i'm having to
do
things like they all they need is you
here and you're you're supposed to be
floating in the air and then you have to
look up and look
super dynamic and cool and
i just can't take myself seriously
me neither i feel like there are a lot
of times where you and i got
caught up in giggles but because of how
fast we had to film we weren't allowed
to
indulge in it we really had to move on
and have to suck it up
and for some reason there is a moment
that i cannot right now
formulate in my memory that i just
remember
laughing every time we were looking at
each other and
feeling the pressure of like you really
have to remember
right now the time you're talking about
was during pandemics so everybody had
mars on you couldn't quite tell whether
people were
laughing at you or kind of like yeah
just annoyed
so there are some amazing new characters
obviously that join
wonder and vision in the show um namely
catherine
hans agnes and tiana paris's version of
monica
what was it like welcoming them to the
mcu family
i just felt so lucky to have both of
those women on our set
i can't imagine the show being with any
other people
god we had fun well i love the
experience because i
remember everybody being incredibly
welcoming to me when i
first arrived in person on age of ultron
and it was just uh really because it
really is a there's a real family feel
it was lovely welcoming them in uh
they're both delightful
funny and super bright and then just
inordinately talented and willing to go
along
and join you in the style and the ride
and
all of that looking back on all your
time in the mcu is there a senior moment
that you're most proud of
i would say the moment that i was most
proud was
when we wrapped one division and just
thinking
in the middle of this thing that has
been that
has sort of decimated production around
the globe we got through it without a
single case
and everybody really stuck to the rules
and really took it seriously
really genuinely made me feel so proud
yeah i agree with you on that
i think there are also moments in this
show that i thought would be
really hard to pull off and so
i think there's i mean things that i
can't talk about specifically
right now but when something seems like
kind of impossible
and then you just have to thrust
yourself into it because it's the day
that you're supposed to do
it and you've been hoping the day would
never come
yeah i think that's true lizzy there's a
lot of yielding i just gotta let go of
my
embarrassment muscle and just go for it
i've talked to a lot of people about how
these movies or
shows like make you feel absolutely
like the stupidest silliest most
embarrassing
moments if anyone could actually see how
these things are shot
as opposed to how it's edited in the end
that's right and i think that's the
greatest thing that marvel has like
given me as an actor i would say
is like now that kind of freedom of just
you know
doing it and not thinking too much about
it just
jumping jumping into the defense that's
[Music]
right
[Music]
you